[Music]
and we are trying to solve the problem
of speeders on our streets including
your thoughts on making it so cars may
not even be able to go 100 miles an hour
well we start with more immediate
suggestions our mary jane valeeza talked
with nyla marquez who lives near the
intersection where those nine people
were killed by a hundred mile an hour
driver she likes the idea of more radar
enforcement maybe it'll help you be like
oh wow i'm going way too fast i need to
slow down a little bit retired police
officer david collier says tickets from
red light cameras would be worthless if
people who get them get away with
ignoring them if you're not going to go
to jail and you're not going to get a
ticket that means anything and it goes
to collections what do you think other
people going to do in the community
and we heard from viewer kathleen one of
several who wrote in she writes there's
no need to be able to drive at anything
over 70 even on the highways long
distance she writes i've always wondered
why 120 or more even shows up on the
speedometer feel free to chime in and we
will keep sharing your comments in the
meantime please buckle up drive
carefully and put down that phone here's
the email address traffic 8 8newsnow.com